musique David B toujours là 56 ans le
chanteur anglais sort un nouvel album et
entame une tournée mondial il nous a
reçu chez lui Olivier l
reportage il déteste les
inter il aimerait se
défiler pourant cet homme est un po
lourd de la pop qui va livrer son 26e
[Musique]
album
chanson qui entre joie de vivre et
pessimisme sur la condition
humaine je ne vois aucune évolution dans
l'espèce humaine nous sommes plus Cupid
AFF vulgaire stup ironique encore plus
ignorant qu'il y a des milliers
d'années pantalon sont Meille qualité
c'est la seule
différence
dandy aujourd'hui icône du rock décadant
[Musique]
hier David B fête ses 40 ans de
carrière provocateur né il a précédé les
modes inspiré nombre de musiciens
peintre comédien il compose écrit plus
de 500 chansons à ce
jour vous voyez écrire c'est comme une
belle
femme c'est juste quelque chose que je
dois faire ce que j'essaie de dire je
n'essaie pas de savoir si ça
m'enthousiasme ou si ça m'ennuie je le
fais je suis un écrivain
j'écris il a intitulé son nouveau disque
réalité une réalité aux multiples
facettes d'un artiste au mil et un
visage
est-ce que je suis le vrai David
B est-ce que je suis juste un masque la
réalité d'un homme qui a toujours su
jouer avec son
image